hey 42 here when you're looking at the
Sagittarius constellation you're
actually looking into the center of our
galaxy welcome to RIF stevecarroll never
watched more than 10 minutes of the
original office for fear of copying
Ricky Gervais character
in 1963 baseball pitcher Gaylord Perry
remarked they'll put a man on the moon
before I hit a homerun on July the 20th
1969 less than an hour after Neil
Armstrong had set foot on the moon
Gaylord Perry hit his first home run
Bugs Bunny was a second cartoon
character to receive a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
the first was Mickey Mouse a troop of 15
monkeys escaped a primate research
center in Japan by using trees as
catapults over a five meter high
electric fence they were lured back in
afterwards with peanuts in the 16th
century gin was referred to as a
mother's ruin because people thought it
could induce an abortion
a restaurant in Grantham England makes
the world's hottest curry called the
widower
it contains 20 Nagas infinity Chili's
and chefs have to wear goggles to
prepare it 300 people have failed to eat
the dish mostly praying shaking and
vomiting only one person has ever
finished the entire dish a doctor who
took one hour to eat it and spent 10
full minutes hallucinating due to the
chilies Michael Christian author of
Jurassic Park felt his professor was
giving him unfair grades to prove it he
turned in a paper by George Orwell and
received a B - there is one lawyer for
every 19 residents in Washington DC
about 75% of the world's food is
generated from only 12 plants and five
animal species in order to legally adopt
the child from Korea the adopting
parents cannot have a BMI of more than
35 in Japan a few foreign cartoons have
been edited including pop
builder to add a fifth finger to the
character's hand the reason is that
having only four fingers in Japan
implies one is part of the Japanese
mafia j.r.r tolkien taught himself
finished at 18 just so he could read one
book the Kalevala
which he used as a basis for
middle-earth legendarium in 2017 Norway
will be the first country in the world
to completely shut down FM radio and go
digital
Norway plans to switch to da big since
FM radio is 8 times more expensive
during World War two lazy boy
manufactured seats for tongues torpedo
boats gun turrets and armored cars in
2009 a man named Felix Bautista who was
an expert on how to avoid being
kidnapped in Mexico was kidnapped in
Mexico after giving a lecture on how not
to be kidnapped in Mexico I'd like to
thank Squarespace for supporting me on
this video which helps me to make better
content you want to make a super slick
site without knowing all the technical
jargon
well Squarespace makes it super easy
with their intuitive tools you can make
professionally design size super quick
regardless of your experience without
writing a single line of code they'll
even give you a free domain name if you
sign up for a year click the link in the
description to start your free trial
today at squarespace.com forward slash
40 make sure you use the offer code 44
10% of your first purchase thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42
you